il est fermé depuis le vendredi 30
octobre ce centre esthétique de
voisins-le-bretonneux ne peut plus
proposer de soins aux clients épilation
minceur anti-âge des prestations
proposées par nathalie ping aujourd'hui
elle compte sur la vente de produits sur
une boutique en ligne cette activité
représente 30% de son chiffre d'affaires
la fermeture administrative
une décision difficile à comprendre où
se situe le non essentiels quand on
dispense du bien-être auprès de la
clientèle
mais c'est surtout que nous nous les
petits commerçants et je parle au nom de
tous ceux de saint quentin et tous ceux
qui sont en france on a pris des mesures
sanitaires exceptionnellement stricte et
qu'on ne comprend pas la raison de ce
deux poids deux mesures puisque les
grandes enseignes sont elles ouvertes
dans le centre-ville des
clayes-sous-bois cette boutique de
décoration n'est pas un commerce y est
essentielle
face à cette situation sa dirigeante
dominique duguet s'est adapté là la
situation est très très compliqué
puisque nous sommes sur des mois très
fort en chiffre d'affaires donc la
fermeture du magasin et est
catastrophique en fait et on a fait un
site très très rapidement en trois jours
on a mis six cent cinquante produits sur
le net on avait pas de site de vente on
a travaillé j'ai deux alternant tu
travailles avec moi plus ma famille on
s'est tous mis à faire ce fameux site
au delà du site internet la commerçante
utilise aussi les réseaux sociaux en
faisant de la visio shopping un
fonctionnement virtuel en attendant de
pouvoir ouvrir les portes de sa boutique